[Music]
as i started writing this volume i came
to recall what an old-fashioned chinese
man said about the white people
when asked if the white people were
civilized he made this categorical
statement
civilized far from it you can't civilize
these foreign devils
they are beyond redemption they live
weeks and months without touching a
mouthful of rice
but they eat the flesh of bullocks and
sheep in enormous quantities
nor do they eat meat cooked in small
pieces it is carried into the dining
room in huge chunks often half roar
they cut and slash and tear it apart and
they eat with knives and prongs
it makes a civilized being quite nervous
they even sit down with women around the
table
and the women are served first reversing
the order of nature
i could have written about the american
people in a similar vein in the first or
second week after my arrival in america
but now i cannot write in such a
superficial manner having spent a
quarter of a century as a lecturer in
various parts of the united states
i not only have observed but have
actually lived american life
at this critical hour in world history
when the earth is reverberating with all
sorts of false propaganda against
america
i felt it my duty as well as my
privilege to write a new volume
based on my more mature observation of
american life and culture
few asiatic authors have written about
america for their own people
who form nearly two-thirds of all human
beings
although i have not written this volume
exclusively for them i hope that it will
be read by many of my fellow asiatics
whose primary source of information
about america is the hostile
communist propaganda but will also help
my american friends
to gain a better understanding of their
own rich enviable heritage
[Music]
by and large a typical american is a
hard-working person
with boundless enthusiasm for work
he rises early in the morning often
startled out of bed by an alarm clock
he rushes to shave and dress but is
often held up by the terrific
task of mowing his barbed wire like
whiskers of which he is altogether too
much for he is about the hairiest man on
earth
coming closely behind the monkeys he now
grabs the shirt and swings it around him
and ties up his neck with a horrible
rope called necktie
as if he is going to hang himself he
then jumps into his trousers and his
shoes
too which was large as fair-sized canoes
for he has unusually big feet
he now races into the dining room and
gulps his breakfast door
often skips it and makes a beeline for
the garage bus or train
he finally reaches his office just about
half a second before the clock strikes
i think this application is filled out
all right mr arnold thank you
but once he starts his work and goes
about it as if he is going to pass out
at the end of the hour
but somehow he manages to survive
through the morning he rushes to the
lunchroom like a hungry tiger
he grabs a sandwich and throws the whole
business into his big mouth
he would have choked to death long ago
but for coffee which washes the sandwich
down to his tummy
he then runs back to his office and
works and works to him
work is his religion his recreation and
his life
you take work away from him and you will
kill him he is born to work he lives to
work and he dies
for his work he has no time to be
graceful polite and stylish
he rushes all the way from the maternity
ward to the graveyard
and at the graveyard he gets his first
real rest
in fact even after their death most
americans do not seem to get much rest
for some of them believe that heaven is
not a place of leisure but it is a sort
of
workshop where the souls of the mortal
beings play harps and sing and dance
with the angels
the bad americans however seem to get
some rest after their death
for according to some americans hell is
a place of rest
where there is nothing for a man to do
[Music]
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
so quick update from coco she's cashed
in her bitcoin and sold her shares in
gamestop
and has pulled a controlling chair in
magellan tv so it's now called
coco tv i will have one documentary
constantly streaming of a bird
flying around in a circle i joke of
course magellan actually has more than 3
000 documentaries and new ones are
appearing all the time
a great example of this is our
recommendation this week ancient
angkor an exploration of the wonderful
temple complex
using the latest technology magellan is
essentially a netflix for documentaries
with the largest range of history stuff
anywhere amongst lots of other genres
much of it's available in 4k and
playable on a wide variety of devices
so click on the link in the description
for an exclusive month-long
free trial for voices of the past
viewers thanks
a typical american is a born optimist
he's not cast into gloom
by thousands of failures but he is
always exhilarated by one success
or a remote possibility of success which
may never come
the very belief that a man can shape his
own destiny was born of the american
experiences
in the new world of abundant
opportunities had the opportunities for
success been as scarce as in the old
world and
had americans suffered successive
defeats without end such as the people
of the old world
they too would probably have believed
that fate is what god or
nature decrees unfortunately these
sacred american ideals have not always
succeeded in penetrating the color line
for instance even at this moment when
the american boys are dying for freedom
in korea
the koreans japanese siamese indonesians
and polynesians are still excluded
from the citadel of american democracy
and those who are already in the united
states are not allowed to enjoy the
privilege of becoming
american citizens it is doubtful if
america can gain the wholehearted
support of the east for the cause of
freedom
without getting rid of this cancerous
disease
race prejudice
[Music]
despite this truly not until i found a
sanctuary in america did i have a taste
of liberty
having grown up under the shadows of the
japanese secret police and
manchurian bandits i did not know what
peace and freedom meant
i still remember how i felt when i had
the first taste of freedom in the sweet
land of liberty
out of the reach of japanese secret
police and chinese bandits
i'm putting it mildly when i say that my
first taste of freedom in america
was as thrilling as the first kiss of a
young lover
all the loose talk that there is no more
freedom in america than in the
totalitarian countries is outright
communist propaganda
or the foolish utterances of the
ignorant and irresponsible americans who
have enjoyed freedom and democracy for
so long
and so much in this blessed country that
they have forgotten the meaning
of tyranny and despotism even the rich
and powerful are often
sued defeated fined or jailed by the
common man
who was supposed to be a helpless slave
to his capitalist master
it is about the only great democratic
country in the world where any man
can criticize attack or condemn and
denounce his government
with no more compunction than he would
feel in scolding his dog
or in whipping his horse it is about the
only country under the sun where any man
can even call the president of his
country
s.o.b whatever that may mean and can
still retain his head
and go about the country as free as a
bird i think this fact
alone to call the president whatever one
wishes without fear
makes the united states the freest
country
in the world
traveling up and down the country i have
attacked and denounced the american
people and government for their
indifference with the pacific and far
eastern affairs
had i done this in a totalitarian state
i would have lost my head long ago
but no official or civilian has ever
questioned my right to say what i said
the only thing which have deprived me of
my freedom of speech and movement
have been the blizzards and the labor
strikes which stop the buses trains or
planes
the fine spirit of sportsmanship is
beautifully expressed
in almost every political election the
opposing candidates throw
mud at each other's faces and call each
other names in a way that no honorable
man would dream of doing
they shout yell and swear in the
strongest language as if they are going
to kill each other off
and get it over within a hurry certainly
few decent men on earth can think of
admiring a people who lie and cheat as
the american campaigners do
but the way they accept the result of
the election arouses the highest respect
of all men in most countries the loser
continues the battle after the election
he accuses the winner of using dishonest
methods in the election and refuses to
accept the result of the election
i'm not going to give in let us fight it
out so the election by ballots
ends in election by bullets but it is
not so
with americans both the winner and the
loser accept the election result as
final
although they know that the majority
cannot be right
always
americans waste little time on history
they study history only to find the
faults of their ancestors so that they
may not repeat the same mistakes
this forward-looking frame of mind as i
see it is one of the essential
differences between the occidental and
the oriental
particularly between the american and
the old chinese
the old-fashioned chinese revered their
ancestors so much as to worship them
and feared to do anything which their
ancestors did not do
on the other hand americans are never so
conservative or
so dogmatic as to scorn new ideas
though it is a fact that many of these
so-called new things are not really new
their modern music known as crooning
sounds little different
from the noise made by a sick dog hit by
a stone
their so-called modern art is a crude
and childish replica of the drawings of
the cavemen
with one difference the drawings of the
cavemen were intelligible whereas those
of the american modernists are not
the american women have not introduced
anything new when they wear trousers or
long fingernails the chinese women wore
trousers long before america was
discovered
one of the funniest new styles i've seen
in america was the so-called
cooly coat which at one time was worn by
almost every housewife who could afford
it
as i came to lecture at a fashionable
woman's club all the ladies came in
colorful
cooly coats bearing strange chinese
characters on their backs
one of them read i am a fire
extinguisher
another said i'm a water carrier still
another read
i'm a big fat fool
[Music]
even the poor americans accepting some
habitual drunkards or bums
can eat all the food which a man needs
and the rich men cannot possibly eat
more than the poor
the wives of the rich men are not better
fed than those of the poor men
for both classes of women just starved
to death not because they do not have
enough to eat but because they want to
be
fashionable in fact the only class of
underfed
undernourished and starving people i've
seen in all my 25 years of travelling in
america
is the class of women who voluntarily
subject themselves to starvation for the
sake of preserving
slender figures in old china only the
rich men and their wives and children
had enough to eat and to grow corpulent
corpulence therefore became a symbol of
fortune beauty and charm
one of the commonest flatteries was to
say to a person you look
fatter than before but here in america
everyone has more than enough to eat
and everyone can grow stout like the
millionaires in china
so corpulence is no sign of beauty or
honor
you call a lady a fat cow oh boy you are
sure to get into trouble
many american women grow so bony and
skinny that i feel sorry for the men
for it must be hard for them unless they
be archaeologists
to grow romantic with a bag of bones
[Music]
of all the things that make americans
happy and of all the things which make
them work like slaves in building their
civilization
the most important and the most powerful
is the thing
called love
it is no exaggeration to say that all
their struggle for success
wealth and honor has been motivated by
love
which has been glorified in legend and
fable in drama
music and literature so when i was a
student i fell for a beautiful
sweet little american co-ed i shall
never forget how i felt my eyes were
fixed on the stars my feet walked on the
drifting clouds
my heart was filled with something which
made me
sigh often my mind was blank and my head
swam about in a dreamland
i couldn't eat or sleep subsequently i
grew dizzy tired and weak and i felt as
if i caught a terrible flu
i did not know what it was at first when
i asked about it my american friends
told me that it was
love it was incredible and i asked
you mean to say this is the stuff which
you fight and die over
yep that's it said my friends well
i said if that is true i'm very sorry
for you people have nothing better to
fight for
personally i would rather catch another
[Music]
flu
modern americans born in a rich
prosperous country
with silver spoons in their mouths have
never seen
felt or understood the meaning of
poverty and misery
nor have they worked for or paid with
their own sweat blood and tears for what
they have
naturally they do not fully appreciate
what they have and are not content with
all the wealth and comfort found in
america whether happy or not
americans have built in their search for
happiness the mightiest material
civilization
known in history
what they have built has served both as
a target of attack
and an object of worship the critics of
american civilization usually say
in substance you have developed science
inventions but you have not
improved your men and women you have
built great homes
churches schools factories planes and
ships
but you have not developed your morals
and manners
you have leveled the mountains tamed the
rivers and transformed your deserts and
wildernesses into farms orchards and
parks
but you have not developed your cultural
and spiritual
qualities of life but in a way it is
fortunate for all democratic peoples
that america has put a priority on
developing her material power
had she been too much occupied with
producing her beethoven's miltons and
shakespeare's
to give thought to creating ford's
edisons and comptons
she might have gone down under the heels
of tojo or stalin
regardless of her beautiful art music
literature philosophy and religion
valuable though they are had she been
ruthlessly crushed as other countries
were
what nation would have served in her
place as an arsenal of democracy
and a reservoir of lifeblood for the
teeming millions
of the helpless and hopeless victims of
war
materialistic america i'd take my hat
off to thee
and i am once again